To help you visualize this a bit better,
I've created a small app to show
you how you can manipulate images.
Here we have an image inside a card view
with a label composed of a couple of
text views.
Below the card view
are a series of radio buttons
with different transformations and scale
types you can apply to the above image.
The default scale type for
an image Is FIT_CENTER.
It scales the images to fit inside
the view will keeping the aspect ratio.
If the axes don't match,
the empty space is distributed
on both sides of the image, either the
top and bottom or the left and right.
FIT_START and FIT_END also scale
the image to fit inside the view but
they align the image so that the unused
space appears before or after the image.
FIT_XY scales the image to use
all the space in the view,
even if the aspect ratio changes.
In other words, unless your image has an
aspect ratio that closely matches your
view, using FIT_XY might be a bad idea.
We have three center options, center,
center crop, and center inside.
Center displays the image centered
in the view with no scaling at all.
In this case,
the image is larger than our view so
we only see a small portion of it.
Center inside attempts to center
the image in the view and
will scale it down to fit.
If the image is smaller than the view,
it won't scale it up and
the extra space will be evenly
distributed around the image.
If the image is larger than the view,
center inside will look similar
to the results of fit center.
Center crop scales the image so
that both the width and
the height exceed
the dimensions of the view.
It centers the image and then crops
everything that was left around it but
not in view.
It can make an already
great image more impactful.
If none of those options fit your needs,
you can select matrix and
a matrix composed of translations,
scaling, and rotation.
For this matrix, I scaled the x and
the y axes in half and translated
a 100 pixels in each direction.
Last but not least,
there's this radial button here.
There isn't a no scale type.
This is my not so vague way of saying
don't use ill sized images for
your views or add large paddings.
It makes your images look lower quality.
Whatever you choose, play around
with images of similar quality and
size to what you'll use in your
production app to see what works best.